you will have doubts questions judgments
acknowledge them
in
dear you just learned how to handle it
and how to believe in yourself
that is Peloton instructor Emma love
will Emma teaches cycling Pilates dance
cardio and core strength that's just to
name a few to Millions who subscribe to
our popular fitness programs now she is
out with a new book called live learn
love well lessons from a life of
progress not Perfection part Memoir and
part advice it's filled with personal
stories and life lessons and my love
well joins us first on CBS mornings how
you doing this morning I am great thank
you guys so much for having me all right
I just rode you yesterday oh your r b
ride is really great I love running with
Vision of Love yes oh yeah okay so
um you are fearless
you are working but you say writing this
book scared you absolutely
um I'm totally stepping out of my
comfort zone I think I've always wanted
to write a book but I didn't know when
it would happen and when the opportunity
presented itself I took it I was like
you know do it while afraid I'm just
gonna do it and here we are it's been an
amazing experience two years of working
on this and I'm so happy to announce
that it's out today okay so it's been
amazing but it's also been healing for
you yes I think it was kind of like
going to therapy it's really like going
back and looking at all my life stories
opening up old journals and Diaries from
when I was a kid calling my mom and dad
my brother and being like do you
remember this story and he's like that's
not how it happened it happened like
this you know kind of rehashing all of
this family trauma and also you know
some Beautiful Moments and getting to
relive them and then write them down
family trauma and a little bit of drama
Emma because you write in the book it's
very personal for you it is your mom is
Chinese your dad is white as you point
out you grew up mixed race and just how
that affected your life how you fit in
some communities and then not in others
could you talk about that a little bit
Yeah I think that I grew up in a
community that was mostly white and so I
often you know looked at my mom and
thought why are you so why are you
different why are we so different why is
our household so different why are we
eating that kind of food why are we
eating this kind of food the other kids
don't do this and I didn't understand
her until I got older and now as an
adult and I've traveled so much I really
now see how much my mom has gone through
she created a home in another country
learned a new language and I look at my
mom now and I think she's an absolute
rock star yeah yeah we should get that
this this philosophy of progress not
Perfection which I think we all agree is
a great yeah it's a great motto right
yeah yeah I'm definitely a perfectionist
I have been I go through you know Time
seasons of my life where I've been
really focused on being the best being
the best and even with writing this book
it was is that Journey too where I'm
like no I need to make more edits I can
make more I can make it better I can
make it better and you know I really
think just the folk there's no such
thing as Perfection right so if we get
rid of that idea and just enjoy the
process like if we're showing up for
ourselves every single day
that's that's what we want that's what
we want to see for ourselves you talk
about your voices your power and there
was a time when you didn't understand
that but you wouldn't even be at Peloton
if you hadn't used your voice because
you reached out to Peloton directly and
said hey yeah I'm very interested yeah I
yeah John Foley I sent an email to John
Foley I had met him before my amazing
partner Dave encouraged me he's like
just email the CEO and I was like who do
you think I am okay
but I took his advice which was great
advice good advice Dave yes totally I
slammed my laptop and like did a lap
around the apartment because I was like
ah you know it's off 20 minutes later he
responded he said I'd love 20 minutes 20
minutes he said let's let's get you on a
call and let's let's get you in for an
audition and there you are and you put a
lot of time and effort into your
playlist your playlist I think are some
of the most fun things that you do tell
us about your process because you're a
great lip syncer so much so that you
give advice on how to do a good lip sync
yes I I grew up always entering the lip
sync contest which was you know part of
the reason why I think I love performing
and uh so yeah in my classes I pick
music that inspires me and hope that it
will inspire you too and I feel like if
you see me
be happy and having joy and enjoying the
process you're gonna be happy to You're
Gonna experience my joy and so if I'm
motivated I hope that you are motivated
too so every week you have a standing
date with yourself I love that too
explain exactly what that is and what
you've learned from yes so at Peloton I
would teach a an evening class and
instead of getting on the road and
heading back home I would decide after
class I'd take myself out to dinner so I
have an ongoing list of all these
restaurants I want to try man I love
that yeah and I go and I sit down at the
bar or table for one it's usually some
like noodles I love ramen noodles or
some Asian dish
and I just yeah at first it was a little
awkward but I was like this is for me
I'm dating myself I love myself are you
a good date
that was the hardest thing it's hard to
just you want to sit there and just
scroll but I did that once I'm very
uncomfortable going out by myself
because I figured people are looking
good she didn't have any friends one
time sitting at a restaurant by myself
I'm reading my book and the waiter says
um excuse me ma'am your book is upside
down no that's a true that's that that
didn't go so well when I tried to date
myself Gail I was going to say other
people could go out with that book yes
themselves that's right that's true how
about the title Tony live learn love
well and the author is Emma love well
that's right thank you guys so much well
thank you we appreciate you congrats
Emma thank you live learn love well is
out today wherever you'd like to buy
your books